a lot of people have asked me what it
was like to wake up to the images that
were coming out of Syria for the victims
of the the sarin gas attack witnesses
and some activists said the toxic
substance was delivered by Syrian and
Russian jets in an attack in the
rebel-held region obviously it was
painful it was infuriating it was
frustrating but at the same time there
been so many morning's like that in the
last six years
it is an interesting sort of you know
question as to why we object to the
methods of slaughter but not the overall
slaughter that that's been phased the
Syrian people have been facing over the
last six years
Syrians have been dying by bullet by
mortar by barrel bomb and they've been
killed both by the regime and armed
opposition to the regime so I think a
lot of people paid attention recently
because there's something horrific about
death by air does by breathing in
chemicals there's something that's sort
of tantalizing about the horrific nests
of evil and you know it's a way that
sort of you can see it in a more more
blatant way I think we've become a
little desensitized to the to other
kinds of death and the problem is after
so many years of dehumanizing Arabs and
Muslims and Syrians in sort of the
global imagination do you think Islam is
at war with the West
I think Islam hates us that kind of
dehumanization has led people to sort of
to now and and to think that what's
happening there is sort of inevitable
this is a question of culture a question
of religion I think part of the reason
we're willing to let Syria go or let
these sorts of things happen is because
we've become accustomed to really
simplistic narratives about Arabs and
Muslims they will never have refugees or
refugees in their backyards they do well
not this is part of the problem is that
we have no idea who Syrians are and
we've had no idea what Syria is even
though it's this place of great culture
and great civilization and great
humanity even if it's consuming our
headlines yeah it's probably at that
point risen to the level where we should
take the time to learn something the
American public in many ways has it has
its own problems but it has to realize
that we are implicated in what's going
on in Syria in the last six years it has
been unfortunately only mostly Syrians
mourning the loss of Syria but this is
something that the whole global
community should feel the loss of
because it's our it's our loss
collectively the places might not
completely disappear but the people who
make those places are going to have
disappeared it would be a tragedy if we
only found out about it too late and
once once we couldn't do anything about
it
you